new in theaters this weekend the little
Hellboy and missing link what will you
see
this is your weekend ticket big hits the
little screen this weekend wait scratch
that reverse it
little hits the big screen this weekend
in this reverse version of Tom Hanks's
1988 big a super mean boss at a tech
company has magically turned into her
younger self again to learn valuable
life lessons about not being mean
especially the kids with the ability to
make magical wishes come true
what's Child Protective Services
enrolled this child in school or
somebody is going to jail that's
somebody do you mean this movie features
Regina Hall piece array and Mark say
Martin who at the age of 14 is also the
youngest executive producer in Hollywood
history say feel what I'm feeling no I'm
not feeling that at all don't don't look
at me like that just look look look the
other way look through it look the look
up there
this movie is for you if you like
fantasy comedies you'd be into a modern
twist on the classic Trading Places
story or you want to be young again okay
see I've been looking at you like a
little girl but she's a grown-ass woman
we have a BMW situation black mama
whooping
your side sorry my bad Hellboy return to
the big screen this weekend in this
fresh reboot of the popular Dark Horse
Comics superhero character Hellboy and
friends must prevent an undead sorceress
from destroying the world Mondays am i
right
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable stakes originally this movie
was set to be a sequel to Hellboy to the
Golden Army but Ron Perlman refused to
reprise his role as Hellboy
when Guillermo del Toro was not invited
back to direct we look forward to a new
take on this beloved character you're
expecting a sign that says secret
headquarters oh I need some ID love um
are you serious this movies for you if
you're a fan of Dark Horse Comics
especially the Hellboy character
supernatural battle scenes or you're
jammed or you want to see a
coming-of-age story of Hellboy becoming
hell man through saving the world
[Music]
it's not gonna work you know cuz I'm a
Capricorn and you're neither a Pinot man
but a giant he's had many neighbors
actually I go by Susan Susan finally out
this weekend missing link this
stop-motion animation movie produced by
Leica follows Sir Lionel Frost
a monster investigator in his Pacific
Northwest quest to prove the existence
of the bigfoot-like character mr. Lee
you take me there I give you my work
okay what is it what the word it's a
figure of speech sounds good what is it
Hugh Jackman Zoe Saldana Emma Thompson
Timothy Olyphant and Zach Galifianakis
all joined the voice cast for this
visually stunning family-friendly movie
shangri-la we call it
what does it mean keep out we hate you
this movies for you if you're looking
for a movie for the entire family this
weekend you're a fan of like a
stop-motion style or you've always
wanted to see Bigfoot in a three-piece
suit that is your weekend ticket what
will you see and check back next week
for a lesson in how to roll your R's
la Llorona
[Music]